hey there I'm mr. wolf and I'm a high  school teacher from Sydney Australia I  teach mathematics you need the  derivative of the inside as well as the  derivative of the outside right the two  kinds of limits that we were looking at  before from above and from below  I teach technology in fact is decisions  of what systems it's a very very broad  category to try and work out what's the  fastest I answer questions about  Christianity it was God's plan to make  us a model from the beginning but he  wanted to make us more than born Jesus  rescues us from every lousy master  that's out there and every now and then  I made videos about other random things  to choir exams so hard why did teachers  make examples sir growing up I was given  a world-class education for free and now  through the wonder of the Internet  I want to share some of that with you  too so I hope you find these videos  helpful consider subscribing and happy  learning